so this potential restaurant shopping
center would be located on Oakey and Las
Vegas Boulevard that's where the former
tire shop Ted Wings used to be now so
far good reaction from those in the
community with the hope that the city
gives this developer the green light to
proceed
[Music]
Cameron fulad with Pro view series LLC
is no stranger to developing properties
in and around the downtown Arts District
converting several locations into
restaurants like Cornish pasty and
breweries like the one on the corner of
Maine and Imperial and with this most
recent Innovation the hope is for city
council to approve his new concept of an
outdoor seating and gaming Restaurant
and Brewery located on Oakey and Las
Vegas Boulevard really unique building
town in the front which again would
buffer any noise that would come from
the a sitting area so far we haven't
been turned down by the city on any of
our project they love
their ideas that we bring
at the project that we finish we never
ever really start a project and walk
away from it and every single project
has been very successful however parking
is one of the major concerns food lot
says this type of establishment would be
for those who could either walk or use
Uber or Lyft to get to the location also
acknowledging that the city has plans to
build a parking structure not too far
from this proposed project those who
live in this historic Beverly green
neighborhood where this potential
shopping center would be built agree
that this would be a nice and much
needed addition to the already growing
area considering the current condition
and usage of the building in lot as for
now the city wants input from the
neighborhood before they proceed it's
slated to be discussed at the February
14th Planning Commission meeting
food lot says if all goes well
construction would begin in the summer
of this year with completion slated for
the middle of 2024. reporting near Las
Vegas Boulevard Madison Kimbrough 8 News
Now